jean cartonne sur le web pour moi
c'était la mère de franck dubosc en fait
dans l'histoire mais aussi d'avoir dix
ans est-ce que je peux continuer mais ce
qui va rester le coeur névralgique de ta
carrière pour moi ça va être ta chaîne
youtube la question c'est comment on
amène les gens sur la chaîne youtube
salut c'est greg iota j'étais juste
cyril hanouna et les chroniqueurs avec
la complicité de delphine d'un christ
des programmes et de david mon associé
aujourd'hui isabelle morini-bosc
deuxième partie donc on va fabriquer
tombeuse de là on a une idée elle est
brillant mais j'espère que ça va te
plaire
on va faire croire aux gens que je le
prends pour un chien dans la vraie vie
donc par exemple on va tourner des
vidéos x soit disant des vidéos volées
en fait ce sera nous qui allons filmer
ou tu puisses dans la rue à enlevant la
jambe ou tu vois des trucs comme ça mais
que les gens se disent et se prend pour
un clébard dans sa vie privée ça rame
dans l'optique de découvrir l'émission
ça j'ai pas et j'ai pas ce qu'en fait ça
ça va amener à quoi s'est de la presse
ils vont parler de toi à ce sujet aucun
doute une fille là tu vas avoir public
du amar closer car tout le monde qu'il
va dire ça c'est pas la presse à vous
passer mais en mairie sans indemnité ça
pourquoi on verrait enfin et moi je suis
et rédactrice en chef adjointe
son patron rtl et s'appelle comment
christopher baldelli cyril le connais
bien je vais lui parler
salaberry aussi qui ton appli devrait
absolument il présente non ces permis de
prendre un peu les devants sur tout ça
pour te montrer un peu ce que ça donne
en gros on a trouvé un thème choisi pour
faire le test
faire pipi dans la rue on a posté la
vidéo en ligne hier déjà combien de vue
là voilà presque 5000 je crois ouais qui
supposait que moi oui savez que vous
allez vraiment d'accord pour ça attends
je vais te montrer et on en dise que
juste après il ya un mec la rédaction
gordini qui nous a contactés justement
pour commencer à en parler c'est génial
c'est pour montrer que ça marche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça promet tata les commentaires genre
cette femme aucune dignité j'ai été
extrêmement choqué profondément déçu et
n'a aucun respect pour elle même et pour
les autres
certes tous les gens y croient certains
les gens tombent rarement dans le
panneau ils sont 25 ans excellence et
que ça me plaît on commence à hélicéa
stratégie du chien le médoc de projets
initiés qui supposément d'accord ouais
je comprends mais après je me suis dit
que c'était totalement bonne que
forcément tu avais accepté que des fois
on est moi c'était un vrai boulot que tu
t'imagines pour une enquête la
crédibilité d'une enquête
la fiq hippie dans la main un continent
série il est tout kg pour le buisson je
fais tout ça c'était une blague c'était
une blague à la santé qui peuvent être
de dire un truc comme ça parce que moi
je veux pas que tu puisses qu'une fois
je veux te voir peas est partout et ben
du coup tu vas de la populaire course va
les commentaires la popularité elle
commande ici ni là elle et tous étaient
c'est ça tapait une populaire avec
l'argent ça me rapporte et je pense
qu'on va vite oublier l'aspect légal
chez toi on va croquer tous ensemble
mais l'idée c'est qu'on se partagent le
gâteau qui peuvent vous tomberez mandat
je suis absolument pas intéressé par un
jean tu veux te demain on est déjà
cinquante mille juste ne fait confiance
ni et pour parler d'eux régulièrement je
m'en rende mais pour l'instant on la
laisse tourner la vidéo elle marche bien
morandini que l'approvionnement je l'aï
un truc vous êtes leur design drame
c'est que vous avez absolument besoin de
l'accord des gens pour mettre un truc
comme ça en ring ou mais qu'est ce qui
est grave dans ce conte a montré qu'en
mettant de chant magicien du buzz en
faisant un jeu simple base
oui mon logiciel buzz autour du puits du
buzz comme si le dakar et aucun doute
là-dessus besson ou trois jours pour
voir comment la vie d automne si on se
dit un truc c'est à ce moment là elle
est en dessous des 500 milles on la
retire c'est la passe et les 500 milles
en continuant laisse monter le buzz on
voit si on envoie la presse locale
ah non pas du tout mais non c'est juste
c'est un point tous les lignes ne vaut
pas que ça parte à une presse locale
je veux que dans une semaine on défait
qu'ensemble temps ensemble parfois tu
les fais moi je filmais avec dame bien
quoi bon je dois vous laisser
mais c'était un plaisir en tout cas
aller de remonter la merde fendu pas
j'imagine
bon bah merci
[Musique]
mais c'est pas possible il y avait trop
de mousse mec ne sera possible
c'est la guerre tant que j'ai vu depuis
longtemps dans toute la ville retirer un
lui est plus intelligent mais kunda les
sens je suis génial je regarde tout le
monde pendant croquer tous et non je ne
dis pas que cyril s'est fait piéger par
un mec comme ça mais j'ai bon clavier je
reste et bien élevé je sais que j'ai
beaucoup intégraux dans ma carrière mais
c'est l'uci qui a le champion hors
compétition mais je te jure que là je
peux lui coller un procès au cul à
l'école où il a trouvé ce mec
mais j'étais pas bien un petit truc je
peux j'ai oublié de te faire laver est
ce parce que tout ça c'est peut-être
film évidemment je suis resté cool elles
étaient bons tout l'inversé
ils savent qu'il existe des gens comme
ça mais oui comme je pense que ça existe
me suis dit ça y est je suis pas un mec
comme ça
[Applaudissements]